foreign
[Music]
hello and thank you for the opportunity
to speak today at today's event my name
is Raul Silva and I'm a scientist at CNY
Innovations
today I will be presenting on the topic
of Bridging the Gap how human MPS
improved this journal ability of Nash
drug discovery
but before going into the details of our
research let me just provide some
contexts of our in the details of our
research
um you know some uh information about CN
bio so cnbayo are a bioengineering
company based in Cambridge UK and we
specialize in single and multi-organ
micro physiological systems also known
as MPS
our technology also known as organon
ship was licensed from various research
groups including MIT and Vanderbilt
University with whom we still have a
long-standing collaboration with and the
mission of our um of our company is to
be at the Forefront of developing new
medicines uh using predictive models
that can provide human translatable data
but why is this work important so as
many of you are aware drug Discovery is
a challenging process and high clinical
failure rates due to safety and efficacy
are usually common
so in fact there are approximately 90
percent of drugs and compounds that fail
in clinical trials we've usually
unsuspected safety issues and lack of
efficacy being the major causes
um so basically currently the current
pre-clinical approaches include in vitro
2D cell cultures as well as 3D spheroids
um
on the third one as well they also have
individual animal models and each
approach are these pros and cons so in
vitro models can be high throughputs
cost effective and human relevant
because the human they use human cells
however they like the complexity of 3D
tissue and blood perfusion they also
cannot be cultures for extended periods
of time and they provide limited data
content
on the other hand when we look at animal
models they do provide complex organ
systems but they also and it also look
uh offer longer longevity and provide
extensive amounts of data
however it is still lack the human
relevance as they are not human and they
are often obviously low throughputs and
are very often expensive to um to have
so um
the high clinical failure rates of drugs
resulting from the current pre-canical
models they highlights the need for new
approaches in drug discovery
so building a reliable and robust free
clinical assay requires considering
several factors as we see here so the
assay should be more cost effective and
accessible than animal models and it
should also provide High throughput
capabilities
it should also be physiological and
human relevance and being able to emit
organ micro environments and address
population variability and immunological
effects when using cells derived from
patients
uh and finally the acid should be able
to show the effects of the medicines and
compounds being tested and therefore
providing an efficient tool for drug
discovery
so
um how do current uh MPS
so current FPS is coming in different
shapes and sizes and they have a lot of
different similar features so these
features includes the use of human cells
and tissues so these are usually
probably human apartheides
or the primary human cells and including
hypothesizing of the cells operation
derived tissues that are often grown in
3D and being in a 3D environment they
also have fluidic flow in order to
replicate the blood flow and have a
better macro architecture of the organ
that we wanted to try to replicate
um
this is all done by Electro stimulation
either by fluidics uh pumping of My
Chemical stimuli and such
um
and finally uh one very important
feature is that we need to be able to
control the therapeutic exposure so
basically we need to be able to
um
to those at different time points and
being able to monitor uh the effect of
these drugs either with sensors or by
sampling of the um of the of the samples
so um how do MPS compare to current
current preclinical methods so when we
compare MPS organ and ship with the
other three classical
models that I've spoken about we see
that
organelleship of better human relevance
as we not only use
um only use it not only uses human cells
in 3D
um
it also allows for the macro micro
environment with the fluidics
also shows like better complexity and
Longevity compared to other models
um higher throughput as well compared to
eye injuries or animal models and
compared to it's a much cheaper than
animal models and
the time to result is a lot quicker as
well
so uh one very important aspect to
mention is that the FDA modernization
act 2.0 was signed into law in December
2022 and this act amends the regulatory
guidance at the FDA that requires animal
testing for new drugs adding a new
section defying that non-clinical tests
uh to include human relevance testing
methods so the MPS technology allows
researchers to recreate a test
environment that accurately represents
the human body and generate clinical
translatable data and this provides an
alternative animal for to animals for
testing drugs with specific modes of
action
so to answer these needs
CM bio have created their own MPS
so this is the physiomimics our MPS
system
it has a unique open well design and
it's easy to install in setup so with a
controller which is that white device on
the bottom sitting outside incubator and
with this control we can set up and
control the full Direction and flow
rates in an experiment
so outside we have the docking stations
which is those two those metal
um apparatus which sit outside the
incubator and uh contain in which we can
put drivers and in each driver sits a
plate
our MPS enables the its researchers and
scientists to model human biology in a
lab through Rapid and predictive 3D
human tissue-based studies with the
built-in microfluided technology to
provide nutrients and mimic blood flow
So currently we offer different we we
have three different types of plates in
which we can grow different types of
organs so we have the Dual organ which
we can have two different types of
organic including a barrier model and a
liver model the battery plate has
accessible is accessible for transvoles
so we can grow a barrier such as the
lung or the guts and finally we have the
the liver plate in which we will be
talking about today uh so with this
there's a different application areas
such as disease modeling safety
toxicology and acne studies that can be
used uh using our MPS systems
so um our liver plate specifically is an
Innovative system which allows us to
create 3D liver macro tissues for
multiple applications so the the plate
is is designed with 12 individual
enclosed recirculating Wells uh Each of
which contains a bespoke scaffold with
multiple micropores so we can seat and
culture primary human hepatocytes or
phhs onto these cathodes which are all
constantly being perfused with a culture
medium by the fluidics driven by the
micro pumps inside the plates
therefore this process allows us to
provide things like nutrients oxygen and
mechanical stimuli which replicates the
blood flow and creates a micro
environment which allows the formation
of 3D liver micro tissues within the
microportion scaffolds so this approach
offers a more realistic and
physiological relevant in visual model
which has the potential to increase the
translatability to human clinical
outcomes
so here is going over uh we are able to
show that
um we are able to replicate a long-term
and highly functional liver model so the
graph on the right we see that we have a
production of albumin over a long period
of day of 20 of 28 days which stays High
throughout this time uh other women
being an important marker of Liver
Health and function and on the other
hand we have LDH with a marker for
cellular damage which is kept low
throughout a long experiment we also
look at different metabolic enzymes
different sip enzymes for little
metabolism which are being produced at
in different
um
at higher at higher amounts during the
for two different
um for different
donors of liver cells we're also able to
recreate the liver microarchitecture by
look showing features such as type
Junctions which shows the polarity of
the cells macro vli as well as the
Luminox bile canonicali
uh we also showed this to be
transcriptional to this table
um and uh be
um and like this we are able to show
also that we can replicate and establish
a healthy liver model
um so once we have this
we are also able to
um
to also able to
um induce a different disease disease
models such as naffles and Nash
so um what is knuffled and Ash so
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease or
naphort is a spectrum of metabolic
disorders which affects 25 approximately
25 of our global population
of all these people with the disease 20
go on to develop nafld Nash which is
non-alcoholic status hepatitis and this
is the most most severe form of nafolds
which can then come to results in
cirrhosis and liver cancer if it's left
untreated
so Nash is characterized by
um the accumulation of lipids within the
liver as well as inflammation and
fibrosis and there are currently no
approved drug treatments for Nash and
the current traditional preclinical
models which are mainly based on in Vivo
animal models have continuously failed
to predict the human drug efficacy
because they lack the human relevancy of
this disease
so our Nash assay provides a
pre-clinical in vitro model which
comprises of human primary liver cells
which are grown in 3D and and
recapitulates the physical environment
of nafld and Ash liver so we use a
triple culture of primary hepatocytes as
well as copper cells which are greater
than macrophages which Drive the
inflammatory response
as well as human hepatics cells which
Drive the fibrotic response in a liver
so we culture these cells this triple
culture within our plates and we treat
it with um fat media which contains high
contents of fats and sugars and like
this we are able to create a Nash
phenotype that closely mimics the key
aspects of the disease
so one of the
one of the very important aspects to
talk about is the our Nash experimental
design so typically in Ash experiment
goes on for 14 days being seated at Day
Zero and then at day one uh we um as the
fat media to induce the Nash phenotype
at day four we run a cell Health QC and
then between day four and day 14
um there's repeated
um
dosing and sampling across across this
two week period
um and in India so we can do different
types of anti-natural compounds for
example could be used to um to tackle
and address each type of Market of
interest
um
there's data data can be generated from
multiple endpoints and deliverables from
our um from our model so we can collect
at every midi change we can collect up
to one mil of medium of which we can do
different types of assets including
Eliza
um we can also at the end of the
experimental during the experiment we
can remove the scaffolds and remove the
tissues
um and do either RNA or protein analysis
um and there's definitely uh at the end
we do many different applications such
as microscopy histology and metabol
metabolic metabolic studies as well
so um one thing also to mention is the
transcriptomic profile of our Nash model
so we have compared the profile against
the uh against the human gene Atlas
we've shown that the transcription
profile matches the profile of human
liver disease as well as the looking at
closest association between human Nash
and MPS model there is a better overlap
compared to Mirai models and as you see
on the graph on the uh on the bottom
that's when we compare the key Gene
associated with Nash our model is a much
better it's a much closer match compared
to animal models
so one of the key aspects key markers of
um of Nash is steatosis stetosis being
the accumulation of lipids in the liver
micro tissues so here in this image we
are able to demonstrate the accumulation
of fats within the micro tissues so this
is a confocal image of micro tissues
grown inside the microports of our
scaffolds with blue being that P the
cell nuclei green bean collagen type 1
and yellow being Nile Reds
Now red which binds to lipid droplets
and here we see a huge like
um significant accumulation of lipids
within the cells uh in our scaffolds
um
we also have another image of the um
another image of the um uh of the
stereotypic model showing the the
thickness of the of the of the tissue
growing within the micropore so this is
a confocal image of a showing eight Z
Stacks so we show actually the
um How deep the tissue is grown with it
which also um
shed light to how the tissue is 3D and
we are able to recreate the Nash
characteristics within our model
so
um we're also able to recupiterate other
key markers of disease which are
detectable in our Nash model so looking
at soluble biomarkers in the cell
culture medium we are able to look at
different inflammatory profiles so here
we're looking at
il-6 and il-8 which you know are
cytokines and chemokines that are
closely associated with Nash which are
being expressed at higher levels due in
a two-week experiment a two-week
experiment period and we also looked at
a vast range of Nash relevance
inflammatory biomarkers of illuminex
which are also being expressed
high levels during 14 day experiments
we are also
able to show the enhanced production of
Clinic irrelevant fibrotic markers such
as temp one and fibronectin which
similarly are being
expressed over uh two week experiments
so our next model demonstrates the
Hallmarks of human Nash disease
expressing high levels of relevant
biomarkers for a long period of time
this means that we can model different
aspects of clinical mesh and then also
investigate the mechanisms of action for
new antennas drugs
so here we are looking at different
models so we can also induce TGF beta
which
um
which allows for a more fibrotic uh
version of mass so basically it's an
advanced
phenotype and when you compare the
confocal microscopy looking at the
um
extracellular metrics depositions such
as collagen type 1 and offers smooth
muscle acting which are profibotic
markers we see a lot more fibrotic
profile of a nationality GF Pizza model
compared to just a plain Nash model
so
the most important aspect of our
national model as we are able to
demonstrate all these Hallmarks uh we
can also look at the mechanisms of
anti-natural compounds so here we are
looking at lfibrinor
um which is am
a drug that was in phase two clinical
phase three clinical trials when it was
dropped and we are able to see a
significant decrease of
reduction in inflammation fibrosis and
cytosis all of Nash
Hallmarks of disease which were observed
following treatments with lfibrinor
so we're also able to look at the uh
different those responsive effects of
both l-fibrinor and orbitalic acid which
is another uh drug that failed at those
um at previous
stages of clinical trials but we are
able here to see that the responses at
previous previous stages of clinical
trials the responses are the same as we
observed as we have seen here so as
adult response we see that the Nash
model recapitulates the key aspects of
Nash disease and the those response also
matches with um what we see also on the
results within the Nash model
um so therefore as we able to
recapitulate the key aspects of Nash uh
and use it to predict human response to
anti-natural Therapeutics we're also
looking at other anti-nash compounds
which are currently being screened
so in summary
um we have shown that
um our Nash model is a close model that
replicates uh close human Nash
pathophysiology so it contains the
correct uh the the appropriate cell
types
appropriate to Nash and it is being
induced by fat medium and it is grown in
a physiological relevant
microenvironment with fluidics and the
stimuli required to induce the disease
wherever with this model we are able to
have a more accurate prediction of the
human response to drugs compared to
animal models because it contains human
cells and we can predict
um the the responses are much better
because of the better mechanisms that
human cells have that animal Stones
um and therefore providing a better in
Vivo
um in which between Vivo translation
we're using the clinical relevant
biomarkers such as
um fibrotic and inflammatory biomarkers
discussed in this in this presentation
and finally it is highly adaptable to
specific aspects of disease being able
to
demonstrate a Nash model as well as an
advanced uh Nash model with
um uh fighting with with TGF Peter which
induces a advanced fibrotic phenotype
and uh that's uh offered me for today
thanks very much for listening to my
talk today and I'd like to thank my
colleagues at cnbayu and I'm happy to
answer any questions you can contact us
via email or visit our website thank you